we went to The Colbert Show unannounced
we just showed up to Colbert and I'm
like maybe they'll be stroked I'm here I
don't know should we go like right to
the front of the line I'm like I'm here
and they're like oh cool so they let us
in just as like regular old Spectators
yeah and the second that we were
unsupervised we just barged down into
the guts of the place where we're just
chilling there Stephen Colbert walks by
and I'm like yeah what's up dude we were
so not supposed to be there at all
that's amazing yeah famous people should
be assassins
yeah you're just like well Stevo's not
gonna shoot the president
he was like Hey Stevo huge fan yeah yeah
cool thanks Stephen Colbert